will accuse killer Robert Tellis is
still on the payroll in Clark County the
effort to change that is delayed eight
news now investigator Vanessa Murphy was
in court today while Telus appeared and
has more on what unfolded
the attorney representing Robert Tellis
in Civil Court tells me at this point
Telus does not intend on resigning
according to Clark County Telus is still
making a salary of about 120 000 a year
while he's in jail accused of murder the
Clark County District Attorney's office
is seeking an order to remove Telus from
his position the hearing to address this
was just pushed back Telus is accused of
killing review journal investigative
reporter Jeff gearman after gearman
exposed problems in the public
administrator's office under the
leadership of Telus including a possible
inappropriate relationship with a woman
in his office as first reported by the 8
news now investigators that woman was
recently transferred to another
department Telus is currently being held
without bail he was appointed a public
defender in his criminal case the next
court date to discuss whether Telus
should keep his position is set for next
Wednesday October 5th reporting in
downtown Las Vegas at the Regional
Justice Center Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now
also this morning attorneys for the
review journal make it an effort to
restrict police access to Jeff gearman's
materials such as his cell phone for
example to help protect sources the
judge saying she did not have
jurisdiction over the matter and the
issue is not at this time officially
resolved